weakest link german the weakest link
yeah like what's his name uh
was it phil or dan which one of them was
on the weakest link
oh were they one of them yeah one of
them was on the weakest link
what's the weakest link oh it's just
it's just not going anywhere is it i
don't think so it was this really
popular daytime british tv show where we
had this like really like she was famous
for being like [ __ ]
basically okay because that was the
whole whole character was that she was i
remember her name
um and she was just a quiz show and
basically like it would just keep going
and
asking questions and you basically like
at the end of the question the round
they'd ask eight people you you have to
vote someone off and it was normally the
person who was letting the team down
because
if you got a question wrong you like
ruin the streak and it's like a video
game where more bonus
more streaks so if someone gets a
question wrong
they ruin it then you get less money
yeah and you if you
so like as it's going around so if i get
one right i get 100 points then you get
200 then 400. and someone has to like
say bank
so that the points get saved so the
stream can keep going until someone
saves it
so if you're the one who's like i'm
going to get the the big boy question
and then you [ __ ] it up and lose the
money that everyone just earn
yeah you're probably gonna get voted off
right right but then like there was a
meta game behind it as well because if
you are too good
then people then then people would just
like gang up in you and vote you off
because
they would have less chance of winning
right right if you were on the game show
right yeah and then there was a and then
i think i couldn't wish one it was dan
or phil one of them was on it
before they became a youtuber oh wow
yeah it's really good you should watch
it
they're like uh the hosts are just like
roasting them that sounds funny it's
just pretty it's really endearing
watching
someone before they were a youtuber like
do it like
i don't know it's really fun i've always
wanted to be on like trivia shows like
yeah yeah i mean i think i'd like to go
on a show that has like literally that
is just like hey
this is just a game show just go up and
do it like yeah yeah yeah yeah
hey play this character no just let me
just [ __ ] go on myself like is
there like uh what's really how a game
show is still going on yeah they are
i think like it's like i'd like to think
that most game shows are the complete
opposite of like the talent shows
yeah like because the talent shows are
just heavily scripted
narratives yeah yeah yeah yeah all this
stuff i think we just don't know because
we don't watch
tv yeah we i just stopped watching tv so
i actually have
no [ __ ] idea anymore yeah yeah me too
there was this youtuber now who's
uploading
um he entered a an american talent show
that i'd never heard of
um i think he's called reckless ben on
youtube and he's like
he he basically signed up for this thing
and then wore secret glasses
while he's on it so now he's uploading
videos of him
behind the scenes and his narration is
really [ __ ] funny
and uh yeah now they're just like
threatening him to
take the video yeah of course yeah and
he's uploading videos like i'm not going
to take it down
this is the next video i'm taking it
down
it's right it's really interesting it's
just living up to his name yeah because
he's just like
he's in it and he's just narrating
really stupid and he's just like a
complete clown in like
the best way possible right yeah yeah
it's really interesting you should watch
these youtube videos
i didn't sell it very well i feel like i
just don't explain too much you just go
watch them it's pretty
really really underrated yeah no one's
watching these videos they have like 80k
100k which is like that's that's still a
decent amount
well for saying like as crazy as this
you think it'd be a lot bigger
but i know it's is it like even a big
kind of exposure that
hey this is kind of faked and no but
it's just all scripted
it's really fun just seeing like a
producer go up to him and be like no not
now oh hey this is your
like oh like you know like when the
crowd's cheering yeah yeah like he shows
like the video footage of like what's
the show see that he cuts to what
what's happening to him it's just him in
the middle of a giant stage and there's
nothing
like no noise or anything
i think there's a big difference between
just like hearing and knowing that it's
rigged versus actually
seeing that you know like all those
talent shows as well have like on
on-site therapists because of like how
like brutal the schedule it's like some
of them uh in like
america's got talent had to like sit
around like 19 hours
to like wait to practice jesus so they
had on-site therapists
and they would like there was like cases
where they're injecting them with like
vitamins and stuff
to keep them awake during these shows
what the [ __ ]
yeah and then obviously you know these
contracts you sign which have come out
before for like x factor in the uk
yeah yeah it's kind of horrible yeah and
my god like some of them i swear it was
x factor uk where
you literally sign away your rights to
anything you've ever done online
yeah and any right anything you do in
future yeah like if you became a
youtuber they own it
like you can't do without their
permission yeah it's [ __ ]
it's not it's like i get why they do
because they want to cover their ass but
they go
like so beyond where it's like this is
kind of like this is going to have just
exploited but they're not like people
want their five minutes of fame right
that's why and it's like what are you
gonna do get five minutes of fame
yourself no i don't think you don't
think so
what are you gonna do build a career
good one good one
not without my help not without simon
cowell [ __ ] breathing down your
throat i don't think so
jesus christ